at the White House President Trump
mocked Robert Muller's testimony and he
called it a disaster Paula Reid is at
the White House with more on that story
and Paula before you get to that I have
to say you had a very tense exchange
with the president yesterday a lot of
people watch it live on CBS n I was
wondering what was going through your
mind good morning to you a good morning
well I asked the president about former
Special Counsel Muller statement that
the president still could face criminal
charges once he leaves office President
became quickly and very agitated he
insisted that Muller never said that and
even suggested that Muller had recanted
but Muller did say this twice and never
took it back so we had a very good day
today President Trump seemed pleased
with the Muller hearing when you asked
that question your uncle but quickly
turned defensive when CBS News mentioned
one of Muller's few definitive
statements father said you could be
charged once you leave I say that again
your fake news and you're right at the
top of the list also let me just tell
you that is go back to what he's not
what he said his correction the
president's claimed that he couldn't be
charged was wrong Muller did not correct
this statement could you charge the
president with a trim' after he left
office yes you believe that he committed
you could charge the president nine
states with obstruction of justice after
he left office yes
president Trump believes Muller's
testimony may even help him get
reelected the Democrats thought they
could win an election like this
I think they hurt themselves very badly
for 2020 still the hearing appeared to
have gotten under the president's skin I
think Robert Muller did a horrible job
both today and with respect to the
investigation though he's had a
different take in the past it was the
most thorough investigation probably in
the history of our country CBS News has
learned the president happily made calls
to his friends after the hearing this
case is closed
the president's lawyer Jay Sekulow
previewed the White House's argument
going forward the reality is at the at
the end of this the needle has not been
moved in favor of any kind of action by
the house
Democrats here the person is legal team
insists this case is closed but
yesterday mullah revealed that there are
still ongoing counterintelligence
investigations into Russian interference
and yesterday I spoke with former deputy
FBI director Andrew McCabe about that I
was surprised that he revealed the fact
that there was a significant element
from the counterintelligence division at
FBI who were essentially embedded with
the Special Counsel team and therefore
the purpose of exchanging
counterintelligence information in both
directions certainly makes sense that
that team would continue to investigate
any lingering counterintelligence
concerns around the president or anyone
in his administration McCabe was fired
by Attorney General Jeff Sessions last
year for lacking candor during an
internal investigation since he has been
very critical of the president and the
president of him Tony
Paula read for us at the White House
Paula thank you very much